each thing that we do anticipate this
deeper falling word into the dream the
dream is what awaits us at the end of
history the dream and you can call it
hyperspace or cyberspace or the trans
death realm but what it really is is
it's a going into the dream and what is
the dream well the dream is a place
where the laws are set by the
imagination the imagination is God in
the dream and if there is a way for us
to mirror our highest aspirations in
other words to implicate the God in the
nation ourselves then it's by becoming
the Masters of our dream and then
creating through drugs technology magic
who cares the details come later
creating a way to share that so that we
each them are a God with an open office
doorway to all the other gods who wander
through looking at the the because month
that we produce as art and sometimes
people have dissed me and my obsession
with true summation because they say you
know what why are you so focused on
visual hallucination which I am I mean I
just it doesn't do that I'm not
interested and then I thought the way
into it is Cato talks about the good the
truth and the beautiful the key concept
is beautiful because good it's abstract
true its abstract but beauty is felt
proceed with the senses as music as
painting whatever it is and so the the
bridge to the metaphysical absolutes of
truth and the good is through the
palpable realm of the beef
and it to my mind this is what these
psychedelics achieve you know they they
as Huxley said you know they they dial
open the valve of consciousness or as
blank imply that thing
window of perception is cleansed and
then you see through into an infinite
holographic recursive rules of mind and
affectionate
intelligence and somehow this mystery is
in the body and therefore outside of
time and therefore beyond in some sense
the reach of culture it doesn't matter
what your cultural conditioning is it
falls into question under the influence
of the psychedelic event for most people
that's frightening frightening enough
that they not not only don't want to do
it but they are also keen to see that
other people don't do it because they
realize this is some kind of a doorway
through which demons come disruptive
ideologies strange forms of music
bizarre behaviors unpleasant fashions
it's all coming from
this place where these people are
messing around and so there is an
impulse to close it off and so there is
you know a tradition 50,000 years old of
shamanism / poking innocent people who
are deputized to be weird and are told
okay you be weird we'll give you a hot
at the edge of the village your view be
weird and if we need you we'll call
[Applause]
[Music]
you